- But when I was a kid,
I was a different kind of person.
Like I was one of those kids
who stole candy from little kids and--
(audience gasps)
- Wait, what?
- Are you judging me? Are you judging?
- Yes. Wait, you're like
the nicest guy ever.
- But, where I grew up,
like it happened to me
and so when I got older--
- [Kelly] Oh it's like a right of passage.
- It's a right of passage.
You know what I mean?
Someone stole your candy.
- [Kelly] No, that's a
really nice justification.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- That's beautiful. Yeah.
And everyone was doing it y'all.
- Everyone was doing
it. It happened to me.
So I kept this vicious cycle.
- [Kelly] People would just
walk up and take your candy?
- Yeah. It was like bigger kids.
Like this was like when ET was out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it was different.
It was like someone said,
Hey kid, gimme your candy.
- Yeah.
- You were like this.
- And you give it to
him and then, you know
Cause you didn't wanna get
beat up and so you give it
to him and then you just go get some more.
- Yeah.
- You gonna get some more.
So when you got older, you
said, Yeah, go get some more.
You'll be all right. You'll be all right.
Go get some more.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
Makes them tough.
- I would-- see, I'm sneaky
though, like as a parent
so I can't really judge
you because I totally
steal their candy while they're sleeping.
(laughing)
They go to bed.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And I'm like, I
find my favorite things.
And I'm like, Yeah, that's mine.
And they won't remember.
I'll be like, Oh, I don't know.
I guess you didn't get that.
I guess that didn't make it to the bag.
- I lie or I act as best as I can.
(laughing)
As best as I can on Halloween night.
I'm like, Okay kids. It's great.
You got your candy. This is wonderful.
Listen, you got a big
day tomorrow at school.
So we can't eat all of this candy now.
Just give it to me.
You guys go to bed and it'll
be here in the morning.
You can take little pieces every day
moving forward.
- That's what we do.
Yeah. That's what I do now.
- Them cats go to sleep.
I sit on the couch, I
start combing through.
- You're like, Ooh, I haven't had
a bit-o-honey in a minute.
- I get all of the
Reese's Cups that I can.
- I love Reese's
- And I like leave like
one or two in there
in their baskets so they don't feel like
- [Kelly] They don't know.
- That they've been stolen.
- They're not that smart yet. Yeah.
- So I put those in the freezer
and I hide them in a
special spot in the freezer.
- In the freezer?
- [Guest] Yeah. You don't
freeze your Reese's cups?
- I have not. I freeze grapes.
I love frozen grapes.
- [Guest] That's good.
- Or frozen Ding Dongs.
- Yeah.
- I haven't done that in a minute.
Like since my 20s. But, like, that's good.
- What about Oreos?
- See, Oreo is good any time.
Anytime. Like warm, frozen.
- Frozen. Frozen is insane.
- Do you do the chocolate
covered ones too?
- Yeah.
- Hey. Yeah.
(laughter)
It feels good.
- Yeah. No, it's just happy time.